premi uno per giocare italiano press due
fori scegli con calma perché sarà in
irreversibile non è che io durante il
gameplay all'improvviso inizia parla
polacco quindi stai tranquillo che se
scelgo italiano benvenuto in ivy scared
questa è la prima ed ultima volta che
leggerai questo messaggio ti suggerisco
di leggerlo poiché farlo è fondamentale
premi e per procedere si premi è
sbagliato schiacciare tasso sono forte
nei videogiochi per funzionare
correttamente l'msc era creato una
cartella sul tuo desktop solo per te per
favore assicurativa che la cartella sia
sempre lì se la cartella non dovesse
crearsi c'è un problema è forse desktop
un bel figo ciò sull'ex top
eccola c'è la cartella sulle ben ha
intenzione di hacker armi computer nodi
mito per la sim afam giocarlo ti perdono
pro guardi offro gelato però muovete
usando il mouse ok aim scared è un gioco
italiano è fatto da italiani che tra
l'altro avevo giocato qualcosa come
cinque anni fa ed è uscita la versione
di steam da pochissimo tempo e non l'ho
mai giocata quindi quindi cancello è
chiuso è un gioco che per proseguire ti
mette delle cose alle volte sul desktop
quindi è molto sinistro come horror però
io non sono mancino ha aiutato la chiave
del cancello alessio let's go o bevi o
fascetti madone nessun leggeri pixelato
hai raccolto il fiore rosso ora portami
quel fiore allen anzitutto stai calmo
perché ti arriva un manrovescio che non
ha idea a chi lo do qua c'è un baratro
a chi lo porta la vigilia la causa 4 fa
vigeva la cassa 4
stiamo per andare a finire nei meandri
del di di satana c'è un letto c'è una
chiave va sotto la chiave apre l'uscita
scritto malissimo all armadio
apre l'armadio vabbè è già qualcosa ci
possono anche entrare posso uscire
hai bisogno di un cuore per aprirla non
solo la mia ex io posso uscire di qua
dove basta parlare di ex cosa del genere
c'è un corridoio benissimo c'è una scala
invitantissima
ha quindi l'uscita la raggiungo solo
dopo devo trovare un quadro è
l'obiettivo del gioco è trovare un cuore
bene parte chiusa questa berta permesso
ho bisogno di un cuore
avete mica un cuore da qualche parte ma
che brutta atmosfera ricamati e cioè la
stessa atmosfera prima delle verifiche
di elettronica me la ricordo stato stare
qua salve senta lei ha per caso un cuore
che li avanza perché mi servirà che lo
dica che era una domanda easy ci deve
essere qualcosa che non ho che bella
ragazza ti faccio ridere se ti faccio
innanzitutto iscriviti poi fai satana
nel tempo libero però ti iscrivi al
canale c'è una chiave qui chiave ruggini
maerk sono state orbo prima non vederlo
mi dispiace compreso la chiave
arrugginita tela rido è equa ci sta
l'infarto però non c'è o una chiave
vabbè allora se didier torno su apro la
porta guancia con un'altra porta qua è
chi sono ricordava sto testando del
ciclo estero al cuore ai racconto cuore
pulsante no a noi fake demonio ai ratei
sapete quante volte mi è successo sta
nuovamente registravo dovuto buttare il
video attenzione punto txt esiste un
modo per trasformare un entità in dati
questi dati godono di vita propria ed
edifici distinguerli dai normali file
del computer in ogni azione quotidiana
mentre sia il computer questa entità
formata da semplici bike può osservarci
e io so anche come si chiama si chiama
mark zuckerberg il gioco è semplice
mettere i piedi sulle frecce e lucky
se vieni preso hai perso guardo e dico
subito easy il solo ne preannuncia
l'arrivo e white face social face
ma io come torno sul gioco riaprire
tutto steam
ciao sai dirmi come mi chiamo guarda se
non ti chiami pietro va benissimo
quello non è il mio nome forse hai
scritto male a white face white walder
white giochiamo hard inseguirti
giochiamo che vi denuncio
non so insegui shimi qi sun terra calma
calmi tutti ci facciamo ho trovato delle
chiavi no questa roba che compare ora
comunque noi non seguiamo il rumore
corriamo all'asta ma io seguo le frecce
e quindi insomma dritto
l'importante che non vi prende allo zio
e poi siamo tutti contenti la porta e
questa eccola qua mai mai mai però c'è
les cobain in lega
eravamo due passi avanti io amo
guardando giù le mani dal tuo birillo
mentre lo fai però quello ama guardarmi
quello si tocca mentre mi guarda come
giocare ad ain scared per giocare scared
c'è bisogno di uscire dagli schemi
guarda c'è un video di frank matano che
fa le scoregge ma è semplicemente un
trailer del gioco ma perché gioco ma ha
portato come esattamente ma il gioco è
ancora aperto
mi si è aperto un video completamente
random sto soffrendo
sei un emo dove devo andare qua c'è
qualcosa che si trova ok forse è meglio
farsi i cavoli propri bene sto soffrendo
è lo vedo se stai soffrendo lo capisco
voi dei cerotti vuoi in aiuto non lo so
la porta è chiusa lo vedo mi fai andare
avanti nel gioco è sempre una bella
giornata quando devi seguire una scia di
sangue per capire come andare avanti in
un videogioco
poi c'è una chiave chiave del cancello
bene satana tra 3 2 1 boh non ci avrei
scommesso invece almeno non è un gioco
scontato mi piace questa cosa
noi siamo
la tipa è tornato a posto ma io ce l'ho
il cuore lo posso prendere adesso per
uscire dall uscita roberto saliamo
uscire ho il cuore io l'ho preso
hai usato il cuore pulsante bene cuore
pulsante nel senso che lo schiacciatore
fine premier che per chiudere gioco o un
bel gameplay finito giuseppe madonna
questa questa non me l'aspettavo mai
avanti ho qua lancio il gioco mi porta
da un'altra parte l'aver ci mancano solo
i posti numerati alla porta è chiusa
tutto è chiuso solo tra le chiavi
immagino lo trova niente sarà un mix di
chiavi da trovare ma possibile che non
mi do la chiave sushi ma questo e sushi
al tonno rega chiama numero uno è dietro
la porta numero uno
caspita mi aspettavo la ferrari bello
comunque c'è la nebbia dentro casa da
questa cosa importante
o c'è un'altra chiave giustamente chiaro
numero 8 o perché aveva 8 mi ha fatto
stare tutte le altre porte non era mia
intenzione farlo non me ne frega niente
di cosa fai cosa non fai non mi parlare
non ti voglio sentire che c'è un tavolo
gigante ma è finito si può aprire mai
veramente posso uscire in balcone e
allegro suo balcone bellavista
fantastica la vista proprio meravigliosa
la chiave sushi 37 è ritornato alla
nebbia magicamente va bene che bello
questo aiutami non voglio morire no no
no tranquillo non ho paura
la sente bella mi piace 10 vedi
contributo qua sì anche se spengo e buio
fa freddo
cazzi tuoi che non c'è il riscaldamento
cosa vuoi da me ma posso guardarti a
guarda mi hai paura io ho paura
e allora il cazzo mi guardi faccio così
schivo anche perché non ci deve essere
l'audio negli horror che ha problemi
c'hanno i giochi horror che problemi
sei vicino è la zanzara o fastidio
daga un'altra chiave ecco la chiave 2 ma
è normale che io senta il demonio nelle
orecchie nel mentre che sto giocasta
roba 92 dove la porta dura eccola
perfetto chiave 62 puri collegati dal
sangue ma a portico seguito 6
adesso non ci sono più le stanze di
prima cavate vai vai vai vai dove sto
andando lega è uscita detto sono uscito
la porta dell'uscita base
congratulazioni sei giunto alla fine ma
veramente ma da qui non puoi andar via
ma mangiare o fa missy ma da sole otto e
mezzo la testa con me no io rimarrò
sempre quindi band ci arriva fattorino
con la pizza guardando e chiedo se mi
dai un computer con il wifi e sono
contento per guardarvi il premier perché
commettere suicidio o timore di non
poter telo lasciar fare nutrimi spargi
mi gioca con me ti appartengono
io ho un mucchio di nomi uno di questi è
r
quindi alla fine era la mia ex
beh
[Musica]